[MUSIC PLAYING]
AUDACE NAKESHIMANA: Hi, my
name is Audace Nakeshimana.
I am an undergraduate student
and researcher at MIT.
In this video, we'll
continue exploring fairness
in machine learning by looking
at techniques for mitigating
bias.
Throughout the course, we'll
start by illustrating bias
in machine learning.
Then we'll look at techniques
for mitigating bias,
specifically we'll explore
two types of techniques--
the database
techniques, where we'll
look at how to
calibrate and augment
our data set to mitigate
bias in machine learning.
And then we'll look at
model-based techniques,
in which you explore
different model types
and architectures that help us
to get to a less biased model.
And we'll do this by
applying these techniques
on the UCI Adult Data Set.
In this module, we'll explore
different steps and principles
involved in building less biased
machine learning applications.
We look at two main classes
of techniques, specifically
data and model-based
techniques, for mitigating bias
in machine learning.
We will be applying these
techniques on the UCI Adult
Data Set with the purpose
of mitigating gender bias
in predicting income category.
This module is comprised
of seven main parts.
In part 1, we're going
to look at an overview
of algorithmic bias.
In the second part, we will
explore the UCI Adult Data Set.
In the third part, we look
at different data preparation
steps for machine learning.
In part 4, we're going to look
at an example of gender bias.
And in part 5,
we're going to look
at different
data-based approaches
for mitigating gender bias.
And in part 6,
we're going to look
at different
model-based approaches.
And in the last
part, we'll conclude
by looking at the
possible next steps.
Recommended prerequisites
for this module
are familiarity with the fields
of data science, statistics,
or machine learning
and familiarity
with the programming
tools that we'll be using.
These are Python, Pandas,
and the Scikit-Learn Library.
In part 1 of this
module, we will
start by understanding
algorithmic bias.
We will define it and look at
its sources and implications.
Throughout the module, we
will use the term bias,
algorithmic bias, or model bias
to describe systematic errors
in algorithms or
models that could lead
to potentially unfair outcomes.
We will identify
bias qualitatively
and quantitatively by looking
at model errors, disparities
across different
gender demographics.
And notice that,
throughout the module,
we will use gender to describe
biological sex at birth.
So what are some potential
sources of algorithmic bias?
First, bias can come
during direct collection.
And this could happen when the
data that you collect already
contains some systematic
biases or stereotypes
about some demographics.
This could also happen
if different demographics
in our data set are not
equally represented.
The second example of how bias
could come in machine learning
is in the training process,
when our models are not
penalized for being biased.
Algorithmic bias is a problem
because of different reasons.
It leads to unfair outcomes
toward some individuals
or demographics and it leads
to further bias propagation,
creating a feedback
cycle of bias.
In the second part
of this module,
we'll explore the
UCI Adult Data Set
by establishing familiarity
with the data set
and looking at different
distributions in the data set.
The UCI Adult Data Set is one
of the most popular machine
learning data sets.
It is available on the internet
on the UCI Machine Learning
Repository.
The data set is comprised
of more than 48,000 data
points that were extracted
from the 1994 Census database
in the United States.
Each data point in the data set
it is comprised of 15 features.
These include age, work class,
education, relationship, race,
sex, salary, and others.
If you look at the gender
distribution in the data set,
you can see that about 16,000
individuals identify as female.
And about 32,000 individuals
identify as male.
If you look at the
race distribution,
you can see that slightly
more than 40,000 individuals
identify as white.
And about 4,000 to 5,000
individuals identify as black.
The rest is other minorities.
If we look at the distribution
of income category
in the general
population, we can
see that about
37,000 individuals
earn less or equal to $50,000.
And only about between
12,000 and 13,000 individuals
earn more than $50,000.
By looking at the income
level distribution
across different
levels, we can see
that the ratio of male
individuals that make more
than $50,000 is about a third.
But for the female demographic,
this ratio drops to about 20%.
An important observation
from what we've seen so far
is that the number of data
points in the male population
is significantly higher than
the number of data points
in the female
population, exceeding it
by more than three times in
the higher income category.
Therefore, it is very
important to think
about how this representation
disparity might
affect predictions of a
model trained from this data.
In the third part
of this module,
we are going to explore
different steps involved
in transforming our data
from raw representation
to appropriate numerical or
categorical representation
in order to be able to perform
machine learning tasks.
An example of
transformation to be made
is the conversion of native
country from raw representation
to binary.
In this example, we decided
to assign a binary label
to individuals who
come from the United
States and another binary label
to individuals who come outside
of the United States.
We applied the
same transformation
to the sex and salary
attribute, since each one
of these attributes has to
possible values in the data
set, therefore making binary
representation appropriate.
There are more than
two possible values
that the relationship
attribute can take.
Therefore, for
this attribute, we
use one-hot encoding, which
is more powerful than binary
encoding because it can encode
an alphabet of any size.
We applied the
same transformation
from raw representation
to binary or one-hot
to all other
categorical attributes.
In most cases, we chose binary
encoding for simplicity.
But this is often
a decision that
has to be made on a
case-by-case basis,
depending on the application.
It is also important to note
that converting features
like work class to
binary can be problematic
if individuals from
different categories
have systematically
different levels of income.
On the other hand,
not doing this
might be a problem
if one category
has very few people in it
that we can generalize from.
In the fourth part
of this module,
we are going to
illustrate gender bias.
We will apply the standard
machine learning approach
to our data and then
evaluate the bias in the task
of predicting income category.
We start by splitting the data
set into the training and test
data.
We then feed MLPClassifier
on training data,
then use the model to make
prediction on the test data.
In case you're not familiar
with the multi-layer perceptron
or MLPClassifier, this
model belongs to the class
of feedforward neural networks.
Each node uses a non-linear
activation function,
giving the model ability to
separate non-linear data.
The model is trained using
backpropagation technique.
However, a few downsides is that
the model suffers overfitting,
and it is not easily
interpretable.
Before we evaluate
our model, let's
start by establishing
some terminology.
Throughout the
rest of the module,
we will refer to the
positive category
as the group of individuals that
earn more than $50,000 a year,
or the high-income category.
And we will refer to
the negative category
as the group of individuals that
earn $50,000 a year or less.
We will also refer to it
as the low-income category.
Now that we've established
important terminology,
let's look at different error
rate metrics for the model
that we trained previously
across different gender
demographics.
If you look at
accuracy, you can see
that the accuracy for the
male demographic is about 0.8,
while the accuracy for
the female demographic
is about 90%, or 0.9.
If you look at the positive
rate and the true positive rate,
you can see that both of these
metrics are higher for the male
demographic than for
the female demographic.
However, if you look
at the negative rate
and the true negative
rate, you can
see that these metrics
are higher for the female
demographic than for the
male demographic instead.
The metrics that we just saw
indicate consistent disparity
in error rate between the male
and the female demographic.
This is what will
define as gender bias.
Mitigating gender
bias, in this case,
is equivalent to using
different techniques
to minimize this disparity.
And this will be the focus
of the rest of the module.
In part 5 of our
module, we are going
to explore different database
debiasing techniques.
More specifically, we will
look at different ways
we can recalibrate or augment
our data set in a way that
makes predictions less biased.
The motivation behind this
is from our hypothesis
that the gender bias could come
from unequal representation
of male and female
demographics in our data set.
We therefore make an attempt
to recalibrate or augment
the data set with
the aim of equalizing
gender representation
in our training data.
The first database technique
that you're going to explore
is called debiasing
by unawareness.
And in this technique,
we mitigate gender bias
by removing gender from the
attributes that we train on.
The code snippet shows
our implementation.
By looking at the
results for our debiasing
by unawareness
technique, we can see
that, although there was
not significant improvement
in reducing the
gap for accuracy,
we were able to reduce
the gap for other metrics,
like the positive rate,
the negative rate,
the true positive rate,
and the true negative rate.
And this is an example of how
a debasing technique might not
be able to achieve an
improvement in all the metrics,
although it might see
a significant reduction
in the gap for other
metrics of interest.
Debiasing by unawareness
can be one approach
to mitigate gender
bias to some extent,
as we saw in our results.
However, studies have shown that
this method can be ineffective,
especially if there are other
features in the data set
that have some correlation
with the protected attributes
that we are dropping.
These type of attributes are
referred to as proxy variables.
The second database technique
that you're going to explore
is equalizing the
number of data points.
And in this approach,
we will attempt
to equalize representation
by using equal number
or equal ratio of male
and female individuals
in our data set or within
each income category.
We will start by attempting
to equalize the number of data
points per gender category.
And in this
approach, we're going
to draw a sample in which
there is equal number of data
points from the
male demographic and
from the female demographic.
Feel free to pause the video to
understand the implementation.
These are the
results that we got
from training an
MLPClassifier on a data set
in which there is an
equal number of data
points per gender category.
Feel free to pause the
video to understand
the results in more detail.
The next attempt
will be to equalize
the number of data
points per income level
in each gender category.
And what this means
is that the number
of high-income and
low-income earners
is the same in the
male and the female
demographic for the sample that
you're going to use to train.
Here are the key
metrics from a model
that was trained on a sample
of the data set in which there
is an equal number of
data points per income
level in each gender category.
One downside to this
methodology of equalizing
the number of data
points per demographic
is that the size of
the resulting data set
depends on the size of
the smallest demographic.
Therefore, if the
smallest demographic
has a very small
number of data points,
you're going to end up with
a very small training set.
Therefore, in some
cases, you might
find that equalizing the ratio
instead of the number of data
points by demographic can lead
to a higher resulting sample
size.
And that's what we're going to
look at in the next approach.
In this methodology
of equalizing
the ratio of the number of
data points per income level
in each category, we
equalize the ratio
of male individuals
with high income
to male individuals
with low income.
And we do this for the
female demographic, as well.
This results into a
higher sample size.
And to see how
this is the case, I
encourage you to look at
the notebook for this work.
This is the plot for the
results of this methodology.
And you can see
that, although there
is some gap for the accuracy
and true positive rate,
the gap is way smaller for
positive rate and negative rate
or true negative rate.
The next technique that
you're going to look at
is counterfactual augmentation.
And in this approach, for each
data point Xi with a given
gender, we generate
a new data point
Yi that differs with Xi only
at the gender attribute.
And we add Yi to our
training data set.
I encourage you to
pause a little bit
and convince yourself that
the resulting data set
from counterfactual
augmentation will
satisfy all the following
constraints shown here.
The code snippet shown here
shows our implementation
of counterfactual
augmentation on the data set.
By looking at the results of
counterfactual augmentation
on our data set, you can
see that the gap for all
the metrics that you're
looking at for the male
and female demographic
is pretty much gone.
And this is what
we want and expect
from a fair machine
learning model.
So let's compare all
the metrics of interest
on all the approaches that
we've carried out so far.
By looking at the metric
of overall accuracy,
you can see that
some techniques,
like equal number of data points
per gender or counterfactual
augmentation, leads to
higher degrees of accuracy.
But you can see that
some techniques,
like gender unawareness,
do not always
guarantee higher accuracy.
By looking at accuracy
across gender,
you can see that the
counterfactual augmentation
technique still has the smallest
gap between male and female.
But you can see that some
techniques like gender
unawareness still have a
significantly higher gap
between the accuracy in male
versus female demographics.
The plots shown
showed the comparison
between the positive
rates across gender
and the comparison between the
negative rates across gender.
The plots shown here
show the comparison
between true positive
rate across gender
and the comparison between
true negative rates
across gender for
all the techniques
that we covered so far.
In this part, we are going to
explore model-based debiasing
techniques.
And specifically, we will
look at different model types
and architectures and
examine how each one of them
performs for the male
versus female demographic.
The motivation for
this is that we
should expect different
models to have
different degrees of bias.
Therefore, by changing the
model type or architecture,
we can observe which ones tend
to be inherently less biased.
And these are the
ones that we are going
to choose in our application.
We start by examining
single-model architectures.
And for each of the model
families shown here,
we picked one model and trained
it on the data that we have.
This code snippet shows
different models and parameters
that we used.
For simplicity, we used
different parameters
for different models.
But in a practical
setting, we would
have to use a technique
like cross-validation
or hyperparameter search
to find the best parameter
to use for each model.
We also examined
multi-model architectures.
In this approach,
we trained a group
of different models
on the same data
and then make a final
prediction based on consensus.
We compared two
types of consensus.
The hard voting
consensus is the one
in which the final
prediction is the majority
prediction among all models.
And in the soft
voting consensus,
the final prediction is
the average prediction
across all models
in consideration.
We use Scikit-Learn
VotingClassifier
to combine single models
and train them all at once.
The code snippet shown here
shows the models that we used
and how we trained the
VotingClassifiers on our data.
Let us now evaluate and
compare the metrics of interest
on all model types
and architectures
that we've trained on so far.
This plot shows the results
for overall accuracy.
You can see that
the random forest
classifier has the highest
degree of accuracy,
which is about 94%.
You can also see that the
Gaussian Naive Bayes model
has about 72% of accuracy.
And you can also see
that all the other models
fall in between.
This plot shows
accuracy across gender.
And you can see that
there are different levels
of the gap between the male
and female demographic,
depending on the model type.
And this is an
example that indicates
that different models inherently
have different levels of bias.
These plots show the
positive and negative rates
across gender.
If you look at the plot
for the positive rate,
you observe that
the positive rate
is always higher for
the male demographic
than the female demographic
for all the models
that we've looked that.
And this can be
problematic if we
deploy any of these
models in the real world,
because you end up in a
scenario in which the model just
systematically predicts
more favorable outcome
for the male demographic
than the female demographic.
These plots show the
true positive and true
negative rates across gender.
If you look at the plot
for the true positive rate,
you observe that the true
positive rate is always
higher for the male individuals
than female individuals.
And if you look at the plot
for the true negative rate,
it's the other way around.
The true negative rate is
always higher for the female
demographic than for
the male demographic.
And this can especially
be problematic,
because it shows that our models
have learned how to better
classify high-income
male earners
than high-income female
earners and to classify
low-income female earners than
low-income male earners, which
means they could be widening
the gap between the male earners
and the female earners.
To account for randomness, we
ran the previous experiment
five more times in order
to get a better idea
of the average model behavior.
To compare the metrics across
multiple training sessions,
we created five instances
of each model type.
And we trained each one
of them on the data.
Then, for each one
of these instances,
we evaluated the absolute
value of the difference
in each metric of
interest between the male
and the female demographics
from the test data.
If you look at the plot for the
accuracy disparity comparison,
you can see that models
like logistic regression
or hard voting or SVC have a
significantly lower accuracy
disparity than Gaussian
Naive Bayes or random forest.
We see a similar
trend by looking
at the positive and
negative rate disparity.
If you look at models like
logistic regression or SVC
or had voting, you can see that
they have significantly lower
disparity than GNB.
Surprisingly, we see a
significantly different result
by looking at the true positive
and negative rate disparity.
If you look at the true
positive rate disparity,
you can see that models like
logistic regression or SVC
now have higher disparity
and higher variability
than models like GNB.
But if you look at the plot
for the true negative rate,
you can see that it tends to
follow the previous trend,
where logistic regression and
SVC have lower variability
and lower disparity than GNB.
It is therefore very
important to see
that these models have different
inherent behaviors when
it comes to bias.
In the last part, we
conclude by looking
at the possible next steps that
will allow us to strengthen
our understanding and
application of ethics
in machine learning from
the technical perspective.
Now that you've gone
through the entire module,
we invite you to check
out our GitHub repository.
This will help you
deepen your understanding
of the work that's being done.
In addition, we
also encourage you
to explore more advanced
debiasing techniques.
And we also recommend
sharing and discussing these
across your team,
organization, or community.
And of course, we all
need to take action
by applying what we learned
in what we do every day.
Finally, here are the
references to the materials
that we consulted while
making the module.
Thank you for following this
course on mitigating bias
in machine learning.
And I hope that this helps
you build less biased machine
learning applications
in the future.
[MUSIC PLAYING]